joining us now former US Attorney for
the District of Columbia Joe digenova
author of trumped-up how criminalization
of political differences in dangers
democracy Professor Alan Dershowitz
professor good to see you you've had a
busy 36 hours let's go back a little bit
to yesterday and I also really want you
to take when an FBI director compares a
sitting president to a mob boss well
let's start with that I mean it really
proves the point of my book trumped up
you can find evidence to create or
manufacture crimes against anybody if
you're determined to do it that's what's
wrong with the special counsel because
they come in with targets painted on
people's back and people like Comey and
people liked Muller are gonna find
crimes whether they have to go and try
to find a technical violation of banking
laws in on which they can hook POG rafi
stars or things of that kind
and even your account which was
obviously metaphorical and in part
proves again if you're determined to
find crimes against anybody you can do
it that's why we have to restrict and
limit the application of the criminal
law to clear unequivocal crimes and
don't use it against political enemies
unless the evidence is just overwhelming
choda genival is for you in first of all
it is now clear that no matter what
James Comey says about the President of
the United States which are disgraceful
comments by a former FBI director and he
has be smart for ever his term as FBI
director what we now know and have known
for almost two years
his James Comey is a dirty cop is a
completely dirty cop who was compromised
from the very beginning of the
investigation in Hillary Clinton and it
is also very clear that rod Rosenstein
is so incompetent compromised and
conflicted that he can no longer serve
as the Deputy Attorney General and Jeff
Sessions now has an obligation to the
President of the United States to fire
rod Rosenstein after Rosenstein
authorized the unconstitutional and
unprofessional search of the office
michael cohen in new york Jeff Sessions
tomorrow morning should fire rod
Rosenstein it is not up to the President
to fire mr. Rosen Stein it is mr.
sessions job and he has a duty to fire
rod Rosen every professor Dershowitz you
have said that the the radon Michael
Collins hotel room his home in his
office was a violation of his
constitutional rights do you agree would
show that it's the Attorney General's
job to now step in and fire rod Rosen
stuff I would do it differently I think
rod Rosenstein is recused I don't think
he can serve on an investigation in
which he will end up being the key
witness and if I were a lawyer for
Donald Trump and I am NOT I'm just
saying what I would say about anybody I
would be making a motion in front of a
judge first I'd make it into the Justice
Department to recuse Rosenstein then I'd
make it in front of a judge you cannot
be a prosecutor and you cannot be a
witness in the same case but to think to
me that's most disturbing tonight I am a
lifelong member of the American Civil
Liberties Union I was on the national
board of the American civil union too
it's everlasting disgrace today the
American Civil Liberties Union out of
its way to justify and defend the raid
on the lawyer's office never saying
anything about the risks that it does to
confidential communications because most
of your viewers don't know how taint
teams work Joe drew Jennifer does
because he was a great display what a
team team is because they take all this
information including everything
including the material that is
ultimately found to be confidential and
lawyer-client and then somebody in the
government reads the material including
the material that's confidential and
then the person says oh but this
material is confidential although I've
read it I'm not going to give it to the
prosecutor I'm never going to tell
anybody about it and then suddenly it
would of course leak let me give you an
example just to bring it home
so we now they we know they raid in the
office to look for this stuff about the
XS Hollywood tape I can easily imagine
the conversation between President Trump
then candidate Trump and his lawyer
Michael cone president Trump says look
that was an illegal tape of me I didn't
know
microphone was on California requires
two parties to consent is there anything
we can do now to stop that tape from
coming out lawfully cuz it was illegally
obtained now then the government gets
that compensation anything to do with
Russia I mean you're laughing because
it's so absurd it's so absurd alright
Joe we have so much to get to we're
gonna carry you guys over the next
segment but Joe I want you to weigh in
on on the taint aspect of this and more
importantly the person that has
attorney-client privileged that that
would be the president's right to invoke
not Michael cones right look look III
must tell you I I find this raid of mr.
Cohen's office so appalling in every
sense legal ethical professional
responsibility
what rod Rosenstein and Bob Muller have
done is weaponized in an
unconstitutional way the criminal
investigation process which should be
sacrosanct and what they have done is
they have conducted and are conducting
now something that is called an in
terrorem grand jury they're using a
grand jury to terrorize people that is
an abuse of power
mr. Rosenstein is responsible for it and
while I agree with Allen wholeheartedly
that mr. Rosenstein cannot possibly
ethically participate in this it will
make no difference to him because he now
has an animus toward the President of
the United States which disqualifies him
from the performance of his duties and
Jeff Sessions should fire him tomorrow
morning